A random variable can take
different numerical values
depending on the outcome
of the experiment.
Some outcomes are more likely
than others, and similarly
some of the possible numerical
values of a random variable
will be more likely
than others.
We restrict ourselves to
discrete random variables, and
we will describe these relative
likelihoods in terms
of the so-called probability
mass function, or PMF for
short, which gives the
probability of the different
possible numerical values.
The PMF is also sometimes called
the probability law or
the probability distribution of
a discrete random variable.
Let me illustrate the idea in
terms of a simple example.
We have a probabilistic
experiment with
four possible outcomes.
We also have a probability
law on the sample space.
And to keep things simple, we
assume that all four outcomes
in our sample space are
equally likely.
We then introduce a random
variable that associates a
number with each possible
outcome as
shown in this diagram.
The random variable,
X, can take one of
three possible values--
namely 3, 4, or 5.
Let us focus on one
of those numbers--
let's say the number 5.
So let us focus on x
being equal to 5.
We can think of the event
that X is equal to 5.
Which event is this?
This is the event that the
outcome of the experiment led
to the random variable
taking a value of 5.
So it is this particular event
which consists of two
elements, namely a and b.
More formally, the event that
we're talking about is the set
of all outcomes for which the
value, the numerical value of
our random variable, which is
a function of the outcome,
that numerical value happens
to be equal to 5.
And in this example it is a set
consisting of two elements.
It's a subset of the
sample space.
So it is an event.
And it has a probability.
And that probability we will be
denoting with this notation.
And in our case this probability
is equal to 1/2.
Because we have two outcomes,
each one has probability 1/4.
The probability of this
event is equal to 1/2.
More generally, we will be using
this notation to denote
the probability of the event
that the random variable, X ,
takes on a particular
value, x.
This is just a piece of
notation, not a new concept.
We're dealing with a
probability, and we indicate
it using this particular
notation.
More formally, the probability
that we're dealing with is the
probability, the total
probability, of all outcomes
for which the numerical value of
our random variable is this
particular number, x.
A few things to notice.
We use a subscript, X, to
indicate which random variable
we're talking about.
This will be useful
if we have several
random variables involved.
For example, if we have another
random variable on the
same sample space, Y, then it
would have its own probability
mass function which would be
denoted with this particular
notation here.
The argument of the PMF, which
is x, ranges over the possible
values of the random variable,
X. So in this sense, here
we're really dealing
with a function.
A function that we could
denote just by p with a
subscript x.
This is a function as opposed
to the specific
values of this function.
And we can produce plots
of this function.
In this particular example that
we're dealing with, the
interesting values of
x are 3, 4, and 5.
And the associated probabilities
are the value of
5 is obtained with probability
1/2, the value of 4--
this is the event that the
outcome is c, which has
probability 1/4.
And the value of 3 is also
obtained with probability 1/4
because the value of 3 is
obtained when the outcome is
d, and that outcome has
probability 1/4.
So the probability mass function
is a function of an
argument x.
And for any x, it specifies
the probability that the
random variable takes on
this particular value.
A few more things to notice.
The probability mass function is
always non-negative, since
we're talking about
probabilities and
probabilities are always
non-negative.
In addition, since the total
probability of all outcomes is
equal to 1, the probabilities
of the different possible
values of the random variable
should also add to 1.
So when you add over all
possible values of x, the sum
of the associated probabilities
should be equal to 1.
In terms of our picture, the
event that x is equal to 3,
which is this subset of the
sample space, the event that x
is equal to 4, which is this
subset of the sample space,
and the event that x is equal to
5, which is this subset of
the sample space.
These three events--
the red, green, and blue--
they are disjoint, and together
they cover the entire
sample space.
So their probabilities
should add to 1.
And the probabilities of these
events are the probabilities
of the different values of the
random variable, X. So the
probabilities of these
different values
should also add to 1.
Let us now go through a simple
example to illustrate the
general method for calculating
the PMF of a
discrete random variable.
We will revisit our familiar
example involving two rolls of
the tetrahedral die.
And let X be the result of the
first roll, Y be the result of
the second roll.
And notice that we're using
uppercase letters.
And this is because X and
Y are random variables.
In order to do any probability
calculations, we also need the
probability law.
So to keep things simple, let us
assume that every possible
outcome, there's 16 of them, has
the same probability which
is therefore 1 over 16 for
each one of the outcomes.
We will concentrate on a
particular random variable
defined to be the sum of the
random variables, X and Y. So
if X and Y both happen to
be 1, then Z will take
the value of 2.
If X is 2 and Y is 1 our random
variable will take the
value of 3.
And similarly if we have this
outcome, in those outcomes
here, the random variable
takes the value of 4.
And we can continue this way
by marking, for each
particular outcome, the
corresponding value of the
random variable of interest.
What we want to do now is to
calculate the PMF of this
random variable.
What does it mean to
calculate the PMF?
We need to find this value for
all choices of z, that is for
all possible values in the range
of our random variable.
The way we're going to do it is
to consider each possible
value of z, one at a time, and
for any particular value find
out what are the outcomes--
the elements of the
sample space--
for which our random variable
takes on the specific value,
and add the probabilities
of those outcomes.
So to illustrate this process,
let us calculate the value of
the PMF for z equal to 2.
This is by definition the
probability that our random
variable takes the value of 2.
And this is an event that
can only happen here.
It corresponds to only one
element of the sample space,
which has probability
1 over 16.
We can continue the same way
for other values of z.
So for example, the value of PMF
at z equal to 3, this is
the probability that our random
variable takes the
value of 3.
This is an event that can
happen in two ways--
it corresponds to
two outcomes--
and so it has probability
2 over 16.
Continuing similarly, the
probability that our random
variable takes the value of
4 is equal to 3 over 16.
And we can continue this way
and calculate the remaining
entries of our PMF.
After you are done, you
end up with a table--
or rather a graph--
a plot that has this form.
And these are the values of the
different probabilities
that we have computed.
And you can continue with
the other values.
It's a reasonable guess that
this was going to be 4 over
16, this is going to be 3 over
16, 2 over 16, and 1 over 16.
So we have completely determined
the PMF of our
random variable.
We have given the form
of the answers.
And it's always convenient to
also provide a plot with the
answers that we have.